PROFESSOR: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
We've been talking about
antidifferentiation
or integration by substitution
and also by a method
that Professor Jerison
called "advanced guessing".
So I have a few problems
up on the board behind me.
Three antiderivatives
for you to compute.
So the first one is e to the 2x
times cosine of the quantity 1
minus e to the 2x dx.
The second one is 4x times the
quantity 5 x squared minus 1
raised to the 1/3 power.
And the third one
is tan of x dx.
So why that you
spend a few minutes,
try to compute those
antiderivatives yourself,
come back and we
can see how you did.
All right, so welcome back.
We have these three
antiderivative,
so let's take them in order.
So this first one that I wrote
is the antiderivative of e
to the 2x times cosine
of the quantity 1
minus e to the 2x dx.
So this problem seems to
me like a good candidate
for a substitution.
So we have this clear sort of
nested function thing going on.
We have cosine of 1
minus e to the 2x.
And then out front
we have something
that looks a lot like the
derivative of this 1 minus
e to the 2x.
So I'm going to try this
with substitution then.
And I think there are,
you know, a few choices
of substitution
but a natural one
is to sort of find the most
complicated inside piece.
So in this case, that's
this whole thing, 1 minus e
to the 2x.
So I'm going to take,
for my substitution,
I'm going to take u equals
1 minus e to the 2x.
And so that means du is equal
to minus 2 e to the 2x dx.
OK, so that's my substitution.
And when I put my substitution
into this integral,
what do I get?
Well, so I have
cosine of 1 minus e
to the 2x just
becomes cosine of u.
Now e to the 2x dx, that's very,
very close to this du here.
So what's different is
that here I have a minus 2.
So actually e to the 2x dx
is du divided by minus 2.
So this is cosine u times
du divided by minus 2.
Now another way to
get to this point
is you could solve
this equation for dx
and substitute it in and also
solve this equation for e
to the 2x and substitute
it in and things
should work out more or less
the same if you try that out.
So actually you won't
even need to make
that second substitution.
You'll just get some
nice cancellation there.
It's even simpler
than what I just said.
OK, so we do this
antiderivative,
we've made this substitution.
So now we have just
the antiderivative
of a cosine function.
All right, well
that's not that bad.
Because we know that the
derivative of sine is cosine.
So the antiderivative
of cosine is sine.
So this is equal to-- so that
minus 2, that 1 over minus 2
is just going to stick around.
So it's 1 over minus 2 sine of
u plus a constant of course,
plus an arbitrary constant.
And OK, and so, but my
original function was
in terms of x, so I want
to bring everything back
in terms of x.
And so I need to substitute
back in, get rid of u
and replace it with x.
So here that's a--
I'll just go back
to what my substitution was and
I replace all my u's with it.
So this is minus 1/2
sine the quantity 1 minus
e to the 2x plus a constant.
All right, so this
is the antiderivative
of this first expression here.
OK, so now, how
about the second one?
So the second one, we could
also do it with a substitution.
This is also sort of a prime
suspect for advanced guessing.
So we see here that we have
some, this polynomial raised
to some power.
So this is 5 x squared
minus 1 to the 1/3.
So how can we get from a
derivative, something like 5
x squared minus 1
quantity to the 1/3?
Well if you started off with
5 x squared minus 1 to the 4/3
and took a derivative, you would
have this 5 x squared minus 1
to the 1/3 coming out.
And you would also have some
stuff coming out in front
by the chain rule.
Well what kind of stuff?
Well you know, it would
be some derivative
of this quadratic
polynomial, which would
be some linear polynomial.
And indeed, that kind of
matches what we have out front.
So a good guess for
advanced guessing,
is that we can look at-- so d
over dx of 5x squared minus 1,
quantity, to the 4/3.
So OK, so this derivative we
can compute by the chain rule.
So this is 4/3 times 5 x squared
minus 1 to the 1/3 times-- OK,
so now I need to
do the chain rule,
I need to take the
derivative of the inside.
Well that's-- OK, so the minus
1 gets killed by the derivative,
so 5 x squared,
that becomes 10x.
So I can rewrite this
as 40x over 3 times 5 x
squared minus 1 to the 1/3.
So this looks very
much like the thing
that we were interested in.
Right?
We were where'd it go?
Oh, here it is.
And the thing we were
trying to antidifferentiate.
So the difference is just
this constant out front
is a little bit different.
So here I have 4, whereas
when I took this derivative
I had 40/3.
So I need to correct for that.
And the correction
is just to say,
instead of starting with this
5x squared minus 1 to the 4/3,
I need to start with
some multiple of it
to make the constant work
out right in the end.
So in this case I was off
by a multiple of 10/3,
so I need to correct by
multiplying through by 3/10.
So we get that the
antiderivative that we want.
The antiderivative of 4x
times the quantity 5 x squared
minus 1 to the 1/3
dx is equal to,
well it's equal to 3/10 of this.
5x squared minus 1 to the 4/3.
OK, so that's our second
antiderivative, which
we got by advanced guessing.
Now let's look at the third one.
So the third one is tan x.
Now I sort of promised you
by asking this question
in this section on substitution
that there's, you know,
some substitution you can make.
But it's not sort
of obvious just
from looking at tan x what
should be substituted where.
At least it isn't obvious to me.
But one thing that
can help often
when you don't immediately
see a substitution,
is to try rewriting
things in equivalent ways.
So sometimes you
can do some algebra
or some other manipulation.
In this case there's a very
simple sort of rewriting
that you can do.
Which is that tangent of x
can be expressed in terms
of sine and cosine of x.
So we can rewrite the
antiderivative of tan
x dx as integral sine
x over cosine x dx.
OK, so now what do we see?
So, I see in the
denominator a cosine of x.
And then up top I
have a sine x dx.
So sine x dx, that's really
close to the differential
of cosine of x.
So I'm going to try
this substitution.
And I'm going to try the
substitution u equals cosine x.
So if I make the
substitution I get
du is equal to minus sine x dx.
Which is, OK, so now
if I plug these values
in with this substitution, this
integral becomes the integral,
well it's minus 1
or minus du over u.
That's a nice simple
antiderivative to have.
So we've seen this before.
So this is just a logarithm.
So the minus sine
comes out front.
So this is minus ln
of the absolute value
of u plus a constant.
And now we had this,
that u was cosine of x.
So this is minus ln
of the absolute value
of cosine of x plus a constant.
Now this should look
a little bit familiar.
Because in one of
Christine's recitations
earlier, she had you compute the
derivative of ln of cosine x.
And in that case you saw
that that derivative was
equal to minus tangent of x.
Just like it should be.
So, all right, so there we go.
That was three examples
of antidifferentiation
by substitution and
advanced guessing.
So I'll leave you with that.